[Music]
hi there I'm going to be talking a
little bit about music machines and life
or more specifically what we learn from
the creation of a very large and
complicated machine for a music video
some of you may recognize this image
this is the opening frame of the video
that we created will be showing the
video at the end but before we do I want
to talk a little bit about what it is
that they wanted now when we first
started talking to Ok Go the the name of
the song is this too shall pass we were
really excited because they expressed
interest in building a machine that they
could dance with and we were very
excited about this because of course
they have a history of dancing with
machines they're responsible for this
video here it goes again
50 million plus views on YouTube for
guys dancing on treadmills you know no
cuts just a static camera a
fantastically viral and wonderful video
so we're really excited about working
with them and we sort of started talking
about what it is that they wanted and
they explained that they wanted a kind
of a Rube Goldberg machine now for those
of you who don't know a Rube Goldberg
machine is a complicated contraption an
incredibly over engineered piece of
machinery that accomplishes a relatively
simple task so we were excited by this
idea and we started talking about
exactly what it would look like and we
came up with some parameters that you
know because building a Rube Goldberg
machine is you know has limitations but
it also is pretty wide open and we
wanted to make sure that we did
something that would work for a music
video
so we came up with a list of
requirements the ten commandments and
they were in order of ascending
difficulty the first is no magic
everything that happened on-screen had
to be very easily understood by a
typical viewer the rule of thumb was
that if my mother couldn't understand it
then we couldn't use it in the video
they wanted banned integration that is
the machine
thing upon the band members specifically
not the other way around they wanted the
Machine action to follow this song
feeling so as the song picks up emotion
so should the Machine get grander in its
process they wanted us to make use of a
space so we have this 10,000 square foot
warehouse we were using divided between
two floors it included an exterior
loading dock we used all of that
including a giant hole in the floor that
we actually descended the camera and
cameraman through they wanted it messy
and we were happy to oblige the machine
itself would start the music so the
machine would get started it would
travel some distance reacting along the
way hit play on an iPod or a tape deck
or something that would start playback
and the Machine would maintain
synchronization throughout and speaking
of synchronization they wanted it to
sync to the rhythm and to hit specific
beats along the way okay they wanted it
to end precisely on time okay so now the
start to finish timing has to be perfect
and they wanted the music to drop out at
a certain point of the video and actual
live audio from the machine to play part
of the song and as if that wasn't enough
all of these incredibly complicating
things right they wanted it in one shot
okay so just some statistics about sort
of what we went through in the process
the machine itself has eighty nine
distinct interactions
it took us eighty five takes to get it
on film to our satisfaction of those
eighty five takes only three actually
successfully completed their run we
destroyed two pianos and ten televisions
in the process we went to Home Depot
well over a hundred times and we lost
one high-heeled shoe when one of our
engineers Heather Knight left her her
high-heeled shoe after a nice dinner and
returned back to the build and left it
in a pile of stuff and another engineer
thought well that would be a really good
thing to use and ended up using it as a
really nice trigger and it's actually in
the machine
so what did we learn from all of this
well having completed this we get the
opportunity to step back and reflect on
some of the things and we learned that
small stuff stinks little balls in
wooden tracks are really susceptible to
humidity and temperature and a little
bit of dust and they fall out of the
tracks and the exact angles makes it
hard to to get right and yet a bowling
ball will always follow the same path it
doesn't matter what temperature it is
doesn't matter what's in its way it will
pretty much get where it needs to go but
as much as the small stuff stinks we
needed somewhere to start so that we
would have somewhere to go and so you
have to start with it you have to focus
on it
small stuff stinks but of course it's
essential right what else
planning is incredibly important you
know we spent a lot of time I da ting
and even building some of these things
it's been said that no battle plan
survives contact with the enemy
I think our enemy was physics and she's
a cruel mistress and often we had to
pull things out as a result because of
timing or aesthetics or whatever and so
while planning is important so is
flexibility these are all things that
ended up not making it into the final
machine so also put reliable stuff last
the stuff that's going to run every time
right again small to large is relevant
here the little Lego car in the
beginning of the video reference is the
big real car near the end of the video
the big real car works every time
there's no problem about it the little
one had a tendency to try to run off the
track and that's a problem so but you
don't want to have to reset the whole
machine because the Lego car at the end
doesn't work right so you put that up
front so that if it fails at least you
know you're gonna you don't have to
reset the whole thing life can be messy
there were incredibly difficult moments
in the building of this thing months
were spent in this tiny cold warehouse
and with wonderful elation that we that
we had when we finally completed it so
it's important to remember that whether
it's good or it's bad this too shall
pass thank you very much
and now to introduce their music video
we have okay go introduction hello TEDx
GSC we are okay go what are we doing I'm
just hanging out with our granny like
what what what I think we could do
better than this
hello TEDx us see we are okay go
have you read the natural curiosity
cabinet I mean curiosity excuse me Cap'n
a natural let's start again we need some
more ridiculous things besides the
cavern natural curiosities yeah - Tim's
sundial hat have you seen you work there
Duncan Watts Towers sorry I'm sorry
again dogs hello TEDx us see we are okay
go and it is our new video just too
shall pass
oh hi Donna okay one we can still do one
better I think yeah that was pretty good
yeah it's good
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
this case
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
investment in broadband high-speed
Internet can help small businesses
create new American jobs small
businesses are being formed dreams are
being launched and at AT&T we're
investing billions to upgrade and build
out our wired and wireless networks now
is not the time to stall momentum or
stifle innovation or investment jobs
dreams and the future are at stake AT&T
your world delivered
[Music]